welcome to other famous Friday I believe
that whatever goal you have whatever
challenges in front of you the fastest
way to solve it is to model the success
of people who've already accomplished it
so today we're going to learn from Kevin
O'Leary
he's worth over three hundred million
dollars you may know him from the shark
tank and the Dragons and TV shows and
his lesson is focused and dominate Kevin
is a fellow Canadian entrepreneur who
didn't have any entrepreneurial
influences growing up his mother was a
seamstress his father was a Salesman and
when they divorced when he was really
young his dad died shortly after but
when Kevin graduated college he knew
what he wanted to do start a business
his first company was called special
events television that he started with
two of his buddies that provided TV
shows that would air during the
intermissions at hockey games the
company though wasn't doing so well it
wasn't getting the growth Kevin wanted
so he managed to convince one of his
partners to buy him out for twenty five
thousand dollars so he can go do
something new
his next company was called softkey
which he started with two more of his
friends in Toronto and City and he
convinced his mother to give him ten
thousand dollars in seed capital to
start the educational software company
from her basement the company started to
take off when Kevin realized that he
needed to focus on what he was really
good at and wasn't making software it
was closing deals he made the twenty
five thousand dollar deal with his
friend when that first company wasn't
taken off he made the ten thousand
dollar deal with his mom to put seed
capital into this new business
Kevin realized he needed to focus and
dominate on making deals instead of
trying to build software so what he
started to do was buy up his competitors
over the next few years he bought up
over 60 of his closest competitors in
the industry
his big deal came in 1995 when he bought
up the learning company for six hundred
and six million dollars three years
later he bought his next biggest rival
Browder bond for four hundred and
sixteen million dollars and then the
following year he made the deal that
would make him famous
he sold his business and the four
hundred and sixty seven software
products that had sold not many of which
he actually developed to Mattel for 3.8
billion dollars you see
Kevin discovered that he wasn't really
that great of a builder or an operator
he wasn't great at making TV shows he
wasn't great at writing software but he
was really good at closing deals and
when he just did that
he focused and dominated and built a
huge Empire you need to do the same find
the one thing that you're the best in
the world that focus and dominate on it
apply all this strength energy and ideas
and creativity that you have towards it
and it might make you or 300 million
dollars as well believe for those of you
watching I'd love to hear what you are
the best in the world at it leave a
comment below and let me know I'd also
love to hear how you are going to focus
and dominate over the next month on that
one skill make a statement put it in the
comments you're making a public
commitment to doing it and as always if
you liked the video and you want to see
more subscribe to the channel thank you
so much for watching I'll see you soon
if you want more entrepreneur goodness
check out the link to my newsletter
below see you there
you